suddenly in The Battered town of nerda
there is excitement
they've heard a voice and desperately
they drill their way down
eventually they see a face
it is a young man named palette and he's
alive
and ambulance is brought closer
blankets and a stretcher are called for
and his cousin and others who know him
dare to Hope
and watching you just thought of The
Bravery of the men working to get him
out working below shattered leaning
buildings that could collapse at any
time
so calls for water for Hallett
but it is too late he dies before they
can save him
moments later more shouting and they run
to the back of the building
heard my sister crying in the rubble
please be quick please please
the grandfather is being ushered away
from a scene he can't bear to leave
is she dead he says please be alive
yoga
[Music]
with the ambulance on its way the search
team listens for the sign of life
[Music]
we are here since yesterday night he
tells me we will find her we will find
her
and with that the sister of the missing
girl rule passes out
uh
more than three days on and it is the
Frantic nature of the search now and the
humanity of it all people willing The
Rescuers to succeed here but often it's
desperate hope followed by the depths of
grief
they didn't hear another voice but that
doesn't stop them waiting
as we left Hope was fading here
the girl who fainted was back she will
not give up
an International Rescue Team arrives to
raise hopes again
and so the wait goes on
what we witnessed here is happening
right now across this region the problem
is that time is fast running out